de loi où il ya qu'est ce que le
logement est sous-évalué dans vos
statistiques
est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce famille au
fameux paniers sur lequel vous vous
basez pour alors effectivement on se
chie de 6% on l'entend et il peut
naturellement surprendre je suis tout à
fait conscient de ça mais je pense qu'il
faut quand même bien expliquer ce que
représente ce 6 % ceci pour cent c'est
la part moyenne des loyers dans les
dépenses de consommation des ménages
ça veut dire que il s'agit d'une moyenne
donc ça c'est comme l'a dit me faire
l'un il ya nécessairement des gens qui
sont au dessus des gens qui sont en
dessous et d'une moyenne qui concerne
l'ensemble des ménages
il ya des ménages qui sont propriétaires
qui par définition ne paye pas de loyer
des ménages qui sont locataires qui eux
payent un loyer
il ya des charges mais encore une fois
c'est re ça concerne la survie pour cent
c'est que le dépenses de loyer de
locataires et de loyer donc déjà si on
regarde uniquement les locataires la
part moyenne des loyers dans leurs
dépenses de consommation elle est plutôt
autour de 20 % sachant qu encore une
fois que c'est une moyenne et qu'on sait
très bien qu'il ya des voies bien dans
nos enquêtes ya des gens pour qui cette
part des locataires pour qui cette peur
d'atteindre 40 % voire débat dépasse 40%
pour un cinquième des ménages locataires
la part des loyers c'est plus de 40 % de
leur budget de leur budget et ensuite
comme vous l'avez dit c'est uniquement
le loyer il ya aussi toutes les autres
charges associées au logement c'est à
dire les charges locatives les dépenses
d'eau d'électricité de gaz l'enlèvement
des ordures ménagères et déjà rien que
si on rajoute la taxe d'habitation sa
part maintenant dans la graisse
d'habitation c'est pas de la
consommation donc c'est pour ça que l
est pas intégrée dans les statistiques
d'un indice des prix à la consommation
mais si on rajoute tout ça déjà on
atteint 14% pour la totalité des
dépenses liées au logement dans le
panier de l'indicé des prix à la
consommation et pour finir effectivement
c'est un indice des prix qui mesure les
dépenses de consommation et donc on
exclut de ça tout ce qui est lié à de
l'investissement n'est pas ce que nous
on appelle de l'investissement c'est à
dire les achats les achats immobiliers
dont les premiers donc on peut concerner
tout à fait d'accord mais on peut pas
reprocher à un indice de ne pas mesurer
ce pour quoi il est pas construit et
quand on parle du pouvoir d'achat c'est
un journaliste alors qu'ils le prennent
peut-être qu'ils le prennent
content tout est dans le nom tout est
dans le nom s'appelle indice des prix à
la consommation